Globes glowing in a snowy landscape
old-fashioned lamps illuminating a dusky
meadow or telephones by a beach their
receivers suspended in midair for the
past six years
whoo noggin Ellison has spent his
winters scouting for remote locations
around the city of Stefania he's looking
for sites of pristine natural beauty
which he transforms into large-scale
installations using everyday objects in
this case those objects are reading
lamps his work explores basic questions
about people and their environment when
man invented fire that was the moment
where we started to reflect because we
sat down around the bonfire with a with
a lot of people just looking into the
fire and just by the magic or the fire
we started to think about our own
existence and reflect upon you know why
are we here and all the big questions
that started them so so so that's also
an evolution of the light
gyoon Ellison has shown in galleries all
over the world
his works fetch prices up to ten
thousand euros for all of his projects
he's had to travel more than 500
kilometers from Oslo Norway only has
five million inhabitants but much of its
landscape is developed it can take days
before goon Ellison finds the right
setting a place without as much as a hut
or a path in sight
to unfold their dreamlike quality the
objects he photographs must appear to be
in total seclusion it's what gives the
pictures their subtext in a modern
society communication has changed it's
fast if you just go back to undies
phones were invented everyone in Norway
I had this exact phone no one else had
them and it's kind of a quite a
communistic way of thinking you know if
you're gonna have a phone is this one
but today it's it's something completely
different
you have hundreds of models to choose
from and I think it also tells something
about how we used to communicate and how
we communicate today
maybe we should communicate slower you
know I would like so once Canaris on has
found a suitable setting he has to haul
his objects there
he carries them on foot over difficult
terrain it takes him two days to mount
160 lamps in this tree he stages the
image with care ensuring that the
balance of Lights is just right he also
has to hide all the power cables to lend
the photo and eerie atmosphere the lamps
need 8,000 watts of power so Genaro Sun
has set up a generator he uses an
analogue plate camera with extremely
high resolution the final image will be
placed onto a large screen I want people
to get in close and see everything at
the smallest details and for me that is
important not just so much about the
lamps but people start all over
something looking at you know the grass
you know because they can see it you
know on the picture really crisp and
sharp and the small details in nature is
all of a sudden something they pay
attention to which they would have done
if you're just walking through it no
automatic shutter release no auto
correction a plate camera photographer
needs to know exactly what he's after
setting up the shot takes two hours and
timing is key if it's too dark it looked
like a Christmas card gyoon alyssa needs
to shoot during the so-called blue hour
the dusky light has transformative
qualities in transition there is
something magical happening and for me
that's the point where where the light
and the nature works perfectly together
so when it's completely dark it looks
really awful but you know that little
moment of the transition is most
interesting and every human has been
mesmerized by this the artist takes 8
shots later he'll pick his favorite
image and make just 5 prints the low
edition is not a marketing strategy the
objects hoonigan Ellison photographs may
be everyday items the images they evoke
however question the wisdom of
production